à trouver.
Valérie Gamache s'est rendue
à Chute-Saint-Philippe
et à Val-d'Or.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les sentiers nature de Chute-
Saint-Philippe, dans les Hautes-
Laurentides, c'est 25 kilomètres
de sentiers aménagés par des
citoyens dans la forêt publique.
Parmi eux, André Chevalier.
ANDRÉ CHEVALIER
- On a fait un petit
2 kilomètres, on a bâti une
petite cabane en bois rond...
Quelques années après,
bien un autre 2 kilomètres,
un autre chalet au lac Forest.
C'est un peu mon legs.
- À 81 ans, il s'apprête
à défendre son héritage contre
l'exploitation forestière.
- Ils vont rentrer ici,
passer par là et faire ça.
Donc, c'est cette partie-là
qui est menacée. Ça fait au-
dessus 30 ans qu'on travaille
là-dessus, puis ils veulent
passer avec les machines
là-dedans. C'est ça
qu'on n'accepte pas.
NORMAND ST-AMOUR,
maire de Chute-Saint-Philippe
- Les renseignements qu'on a
eus, c'est qu'il y avait
une coupe qui était pour être
faite cet automne.
- La municipalité demande
un moratoire sur la coupe,
le temps de démontrer
au gouvernement qu'il ne fait
pas une bonne affaire.
- Nous, ça fait au-dessus
de 400 000 $ qu'on met en deux
ans, autant pour le chemin
que pour la bâtisse, pour
les aménagements, pour une coupe
qui va rapporter 5000-10 000 $
au gouvernement.
- André Chevalier, lui, est prêt
à tout pour empêcher l'abattage.
- Ce que j'ai trouvé, moi,
c'est de planter des clous
dans les arbres. Ce n'est pas
de la désobéissance civile,
c'est... de la dissidence.
Je ne me sens pas lié par
les lois qu'ils ont faites.
(chant d'oiseau)
- La dissidence, le militant
écologiste Henri Jacob connaît
bien ça.
HENRI JACOB,
président, Action boréale
- On est présentement dans
des sentiers qu'on a aménagés,
qu'on appelle "les sentiers
de l'École buissonnière".
- C'est en créant des sentiers
qu'il est parvenu à préserver
ce bout de forêt, à Val-d'Or.
- C'était dans le but de mettre
des bâtons dans les roues
à l'exploitation forestière,
fait qu'on a aménagé des
sentiers à toutes les places
où ils voulaient aller faire
de la récolte et c'est depuis
1983, donc c'est probablement
la plus vieille aire protégée
du Québec.
- Lorsque le gouvernement
Legault a désigné 17 %
du territoire du Québec
aire protégée, en décembre,
Henri Jacob avait espoir
que ce genre d'action citoyenne
ne soit plus nécessaire.
Il déplore aujourd'hui
que le territoire protégé
soit peu accessible.
- On a eu, au sud du 49e,
0,8 % d'augmentation, alors
que 99,2 % a été dans le nord.
- Le bois c'est pas juste
des 2 x 4.
- Ambroise Lycke est directeur
du plus récent parc national
du Québec. Le parc Opémican
a été inauguré il y deux ans,
au Témiscamingue.
AMBROISE LYCKE, directeur,
parc national d'Opémican
- Parce que veut veut pas,
aussi, bien ça amène
de l'activité économique,
nos parc nationaux. T'sais,
un parc national, globalement,
pour chaque jour de visite,
c'est une soixantaine de dollars
de retombées.
- Pourtant, le parc a été créé
à force de compromis.
- Le parc national d'Opémican,
ce n'est pas un parc en un seul
tenant, hein? C'est un parc
qui est morcelé, donc comment
est-ce qu'on peut le concilier
aux activités déjà en place
sur le territoire? Il y avait
des activités, des projets
au niveau hydro-électrique,
il y avait des activités
forestières...
PIERRE CORBEIL,
maire de Val-d'Or
- Le parc Opémican, ici,
ça a été une longue et lente
opération.
- Le maire de Val-d'Or était aux
premières loges des négociations
lorsque le gouvernement
du Québec a donné le feu vert
à la création du parc.
Pierre Corbeil était alors
ministre de la Forêt.
- Je pense que c'est devenu
un outil de développement
économique qui est différent
de la transformation, mais
qui doit exister aussi.
- Il sait plus que quiconque
que la conciliation entre
l'industrie forestière
et ceux qui veulent préserver
les milieux naturels requiert
son lot la patience.
- Les gens voudraient avoir une
aire protégée. "J'en ai besoin
d'une, j'en veux une, je la veux
là, puis c'est comme ça".
Ça ne marche pas comme ça.
- Selon lui, pour être plus
efficace, le gouvernement
devrait faire davantage
confiance aux gens qui vivent
sur les territoires convoités.
- Parce que je compare souvent
ça que c'est... Le territoire
forestier, entre autres, c'est
notre gagne-pain, mais c'est
aussi notre terrain de jeu.
♪ ♪ ♪
- À Chute-Saint-Philippe,
les citoyens cherchent aussi
cet équilibre. Pour l'instant,
il semble difficile à trouver.
- Une coupe forestière, c'est
un moteur de développement.
On y croit vraiment, mais il
faut qu'il y ait un besoin
du milieu pour que la coupe
soit valable.
- La lutte, là, c'est entre
le bien-être des citoyens
et le profit des entreprises.
Ça ne toucherait même pas
aux emplois. Mais entre
les dividendes versées aux
actionnaires, puis notre bien-
être, on ne va pas sacrifier
notre bien-être pour
les actionnaires... fait
qu'on va planter des clous.
- Ici Valérie Gamache
Radio-Canada,
Chute-Saint-Philippe.